what up guys welcome to the just pearly
thanks YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts I actually
haven't had coffee in so long
I found like I think I quit it in
December January February four months
can you guys believe it
I've been so close to Breaking recently
oh my gosh I've been so close but I
haven't I haven't
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and most importantly
if you guys would like to attend one of
our events make sure you sign up um in
the link in the description
um we're gonna do events and just small
meetups
and me and blessing are gonna figure out
how we're gonna do it this week but
we're just gonna do small meetups and
each City that we go to
um I was gonna do a big one million
party and I was thinking I was like I
haven't even really done meetups yet so
I should probably start with a meet up
so I think we're gonna do one in London
this month because my goal
um next I leave at the end of next month
to go to the US
um for about three weeks
during that time we're probably gonna do
meetups in La Vegas Nashville
um
oh in Chicago in Chicago I'm probably
just gonna do like
anyways if you want to be notified
um please sign up for the Forum in the
description Okay so
I now drink green tea in the morning
anyways
I want to talk about life lessons that I
learned from volleyball
um so
you guys know that volleyball had a lot
of pros and cons to being a volleyball
player and I think a lot about if
if I'm happy that I played okay because
part of me feels like I missed out on
being as like domestic as I could have
been like
you know I don't I'm not very neat
um you know I don't
I I'm becoming a good cook but that's
something I had to learn later
um so I go and honestly you don't spend
as much time with your family because
you're in the gym so much and I was just
someone like I'm just a passionate
person so when I do something I just go
all in like I am just passionate about
it whether it is you know um the first
20 I don't know three four years of my
life it was volleyball right
um and my goal was always to win a
National Championship like that was my
dream okay that that was the only thing
I wanted in life
um
which is a bit sad
you know
um but
so
but what people don't realize about my
life in high school is it was so hectic
and it's always been hectic but
I went to school 30 minutes from my
house I lived I went to a Catholic
school so it's private and I also played
Club volleyball which was 45 minutes
from
from my school so I would drive 30
minutes to school and I played
basketball too and I also played soccer
one or two years
so what I would do is I would go to
school and then I would have my school
sports so basketball was like six months
of the year you know soccer was like
three the year I did that so like nine
months of the year I would have two
practices a day so I'd get off of school
then I would go do my school practice
and that was like let's just say school
gets out at three so you do
um I don't know four four to five to
seven okay then you drive from schools
45 minutes and your coaches know you're
coming from practice to practice you
7 45 to like 10 o'clock at night and
that was at least at least three or four
days a week and on the weekends
oftentimes you'd have tournaments so
you'd either have basketball games or
volleyball games and you would travel
often times out of state so
as a team you go to a different state
and you play volleyball and you know I
want to first talk about the pros of
like what I learned from volleyball and
why it was a good thing so
I won it taught me to work hard and I
don't really care I know the mana's fear
doesn't value like women working hard we
don't want women that work too hard
right
career over family but
parenting is hard work
I mean it's not like you know running a
multi-million dollar Corporation you
know I'm not going to compare it but to
act like
you want a girl that's just doing
nothing
that look it that doesn't work in my
family for what we look for both the men
and the women no because the girls they
have to
help plan the vacations
a lot of times you're doing all this
crazy stuff you know you gotta
coordinate the kids where they're coming
and going well anyways look at it
you gotta cook you gotta click like
so
anyways back to the sports so
six seven days a week I'm gone I'm not
even there even on Sundays we had Sports
so you're traveling out of state and
really it taught me to work hard because
I started at the bottom T and it taught
me that hard work pays off right because
when I was
13 or 14 I joined the club and
school volleyball is it's pretty
impossible I don't want to say
impossible it's quite hard to make it to
the varsity level if you don't play Club
and I started Club late so I was 14
which you I know to the outside world
that's like crazy it's late at 14 to
start being out of the house five days a
week
yeah it is yeah it is so at 14
I joined and I wasn't very good right I
was on the bottom team there was three
teams that went black team red team
white teams nothing to do with race it's
just how they ranked them white was the
worst one and I started on white and I
didn't even play I was a benchwarmer I I
played a little bit but not much and I
worked really hard and the next year I
started on the third team and you know
the year after that I made it to the
second team and the year after that I
started on the second team and the year
after that so by my senior year I made
it to the ones team at my club because I
just worked incredibly hard
and I don't I don't think there's
another girl that did that it was just
me to be honest I just worked I all I
cared about was volleyball now
because my goal I wanted to win a
National Championship
now I went to college and
so I learned to work hard so I went to
college okay and my first college I went
to the school called Ohio Northern
and
I was just a bit different than the
girls there
um
I was on a team
and I came in and I was a freshman and I
just I killed it because I decided to go
to a D3 school now I had mostly division
two offers but I had a couple D1 offers
um I mean nothing crazy good you know
mostly
schools that were okay or you know on
the lower level and I just felt like I
wanted to win a National Championship
and I didn't think that I could do it at
a D1 or a D2 level
um I didn't think it was realistic I
really wanted to make sure I played
I felt like this was the last four years
I was gonna play volleyball I you know I
didn't know about England or think about
England at the time
I want to get playing time for all four
years so I'm gonna go to D3 School we're
gonna dominate we're gonna win the
championship
so I went there I got freshman of the
year I got all conference I was like I
had a great year but a lot of people
didn't know that the girls like bullied
me on that team oh my gosh it was
horrible and to be fair you know I was a
bit cocky you know I came in and I
thought I was hot [__] and I was hot
[__] to be honest they can't even deny
that these girls but these girls were so
mean to me they were so mean to me it
was like
they're so mean to me and you know I'm
not gonna stand and play a part I'm sure
I did so I ended up transferring
and going to a different school so I
went to a second school and the school
was called Elmhurst
and Alan Harris was a bit more
competitive
um
it was a better division three school
they were top 20 in the country
and when I got there my position I was
in middle and there was a middle in the
first there was a first middle there's
two middles that play on the court and
it's not like basketball where you're
fighting for playing time with each
other like
you both get the same amount of playing
time like based on the rotations
um I mean one maybe starts front row so
they they maybe play but it's basically
the same you're not really fighting that
much
um so what happened was the girl on the
first team the first team girl the first
rotation girl
she was really good she was better than
me to this day I'll say better than me
Mary you deserve the playing time you
got second team girl this girl
was not better than me but she could
jump she could jump so high guys she
could she could jump to the she could
touch 10 okay the most I had to work so
hard to touch 910 in my career that's
the highest approach touch jump I have
it's two inches under the rim now this
girl touched like 10-2 I think at her
Peak or whatever
and I just couldn't get there like I
just ah guys I worked so hard like you
didn't even know I wanted to play so bad
and what would happen was the coaches
felt like they could make her good and
she had more potential than me so what
happened was it didn't matter how well I
played they would still sit me and I
went from playing I'd never not played
a full season right or actually I still
never didn't play a full scene I always
played a little bit but
that was like one of the most I'd ever
been sat and I transferred in and I
really thought I was gonna play because
I was a freshman of the year I was all
conference on my old school and I came
in and I was humbled so quick
and the worst part was there was nothing
I could do guys I can't even explain the
level of frustration do you know what
it's like
to
and I'll and I know what you're thinking
because I would always think this when I
heard people talk
oh shut up you're just whining about the
coaches
no no no no no no no let me explain
first one
she was better than me second girl guys
one time they put me in and I got all
tournament Off the Bench that wall
tournament is goes to some of the best
girls in the tournament
uh they put me in I got all tournament
off of the bench
these people sat me
they sat me every stat I had was better
than that girls I had she hit 100 I hit
300.
do you know what that's like
to get 10 15 kills in a game that's good
guys at 300 that's good
and then this girl is hitting 100 which
means like 10 of the ball she hits her
kills and
they're still playing her no matter what
you do oh my gosh and I didn't want to
transfer again because I'd already
transferred once you know it came with a
lot of issues that I didn't really think
about
um
where I didn't like for the first year
or two I really didn't like the second
school as much as the first school and I
had these coaches that no matter how
hard I worked
they would not put me in it was crazy no
matter how good I did
guys there were so many times where we
would be losing that would put me in and
I would be the key player that would
make us win and I'm not even saying that
to be cocky like I could think of times
this girl kept killing us and they put
me in I got like three stuffs in a row
but it didn't matter because in their
head this girl was going to be the next
big thing if they could just train her
and Coach her enough and I went to my
dad and I was so guys this is the most
frustrated eye because I've always felt
like an internal locus of control like I
can control it I can change it
um
but this one it was like there was
nothing I could do it didn't matter and
I'd even had meetings with my coaches
where
they basically said that they're like
yeah well she could be good
you're better off the bench what the
[__] do you mean I'm better off the
bench you don't start me oh my God but
here what was the lesson that I learned
from this guys you're always there's
always going to be a shitty boss
they're they're actually maybe that I
should have transferred third time don't
let your pride get in the way but but no
in all seriousness there's always going
to be a shitty boss there's always going
to be a shitty coach there's always
going to be a shitty teacher in life you
can't always control the people around
you all you can control is you
so I really had to look Inward and say
you know what
I can't control them but I can control
me
I can control me
and I ended up learning like two new
positions I like now I can play right
side and outside and I couldn't before
this I literally learned two positions
so I could get on the court more
consistently yeah because I felt like if
they weren't gonna put me in over her
they sure as hell could put me in over a
different girl oh my gosh and guys this
was all I cared about this was like my
yeah so now volleyball taught me to work
hard it taught me that you can't always
control other people and it taught me
teamwork and how to get along with
people because
it doesn't matter if you dislike someone
you guys are working towards a common
goal you're working towards a common
goal and that's important
now what did volleyball make me miss out
on
a social life
a boyfriend
you know in high school I just wasn't
worried about I mean college is a little
different because you have a little bit
more free time in college and maybe my
mom always felt like in high school you
really shouldn't be dating like that
you know pros and cons right but
yeah and it also really had me miss out
on domestic skills right because in all
honesty when are you gonna learn to cook
and clean like me and my mom were
talking about this out of all my sisters
I have five sisters the most domestic
one is the one that sucked at sports the
one that I would say has the most like
cleaning and cooking abilities is the
one that that was honestly trash like
she's just terrible terrible at Sports
and sports were just such a big thing in
my family like we wanted the girls the
boys everyone plays Sports
um
now but the here what's the pro of this
right when you have a work ethic
you can learn damn near anything
I mean I don't mean to brag guys but I'm
already becoming a decent cook and this
is only a year or two it's like almost
when you have an insane work ethic it's
almost like a superpower like you can
almost learn anything and do anything
because one you're convinced you can and
that's half the battle and two you know
whatever you want to do you can learn
so
pros and cons I don't know guys now what
other lessons did I learn from
volleyball
what other lessons did I learn from
I also learned that
sometimes [__] aren't gonna like you
there ain't [__] you can do about it and
you can't win I felt like like some of
you guys felt
you can't win with these modern women
you can't go chasing after them because
no matter how nice you are no matter how
kind you are it doesn't matter
you know there were times a lot of times
over my career
where
I always I always had a couple friends
on the team but to say I was popular
one I didn't have time to be popular
most girls one sport Pearl was a two and
even at times three
I just loved playing I just loved to do
so fun
um
but everything comes at a cost guys
and in life you really got to think
about choices and trade-offs and to be
honest you don't make a lot of money
from volleyball
what do you really get out of it
work ethic that's what I got you know
pros and cons
I also learned that men are better
coaches and women
if I look back
it's such a weird dynamic in volleyball
because a lot of these women don't have
children and they really look at you as
their children
and that's not healthy guys and that's
the thing like the the con of volleyball
is it really does and can
a lot of girls get married to these
Sports so instead of having a family
instead of having kids they
you know they get married to the sport
speaking of which guys a lot of people
don't know I'm still in volleyball
I've been doing volleyball the whole
year
now
I am a big
I believe so because I started this I
was gonna finish it
but oh my God it was too much why do you
think I look so tired all the time
because guys on Saturdays I will
literally go do the volleyball game and
then come after I'll go to practice and
then come after and has this has gotten
bigger and bigger and bigger because
when I started guys it was just a little
YouTube channel oh just bring the girls
over after practice let's have them
shoot the [__] whatever
guys like
it didn't start like this huge operation
I was counting the people around here I
was like oh my God
I was like oh there's people here all
the time
I'm going nuts but it didn't it didn't
start like that right I was my own
producer I was my own everything you
know and
yeah it's been it's been too much so
the lessons that I learned from
volleyball and I've been talking
teaches you how to work hard it taught
me you could really achieve anything you
want but you miss out on some of the
domestic skills
and you really don't spend as much time
with your family as you'd like
and you know
and sometimes you spend more time with
coaches than you do because think about
it if I go to school for seven hours a
day and then after school I go to
practice for four hours a day when am I
seeing my parents
you know the two two hours for each
practice plus driving
I wouldn't get home until like 10
o'clock at night I'd leave in the
morning and I'd get home at 10 o'clock
at night
now look I'm a very skilled individual I
have a lot of skills
but yeah pros and cons you know let me
know what you think in the comments
I don't sometimes I think about it I
don't know if I regret it
but
because I really enjoy playing but
if anything I wish
I could have did it more like with my
family like we all did different sports
and it just would have been easier if we
all did the same sport
[Music]
um but anyways let me know in the
comments what you guys think like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell I'll
talk to you next time